boom a boat the gods have given me in
recent years big actors like Chris Pratt
The Rock and Margot Robbie are taking on
roles and animated movies more and more
actors and actresses perform for unseen
audiences you can see the appeal roll up
to work in your pajamas and say a few
lines into a microphone seems like a
sweet gig great it actually takes months
of training and sometimes years and when
I've worked with people that are on
Broadway and celebrities almost always
and these are actors and almost always
they'll say to me I had no idea so how
exactly do actors prepare for animated
rules we went straight to the experts to
find out hi I'm Rudy Gaskin CEO of the
Society of voice Arts and Sciences here
with my partner Joan to talk about all
things voice acting Joan and Rudy have
been teaching their craft for over 25
years we work with phil lamarr who's
who's the voice of one of the voices of
Family Guy and Nancy Cartwright who's
voice of Bart Simpson your attention
please your attention please I have an
announcement to make you wouldn't
believe a 60 year old woman is that
adolescents voice but she is she's
extraordinary but talent is only part of
the equation when it's just your voice
doing all the work you have to make sure
that instrument is in tip-top shape
Voice coaches lead actors through a
variety of exercises to optimize their
vocal chords and condition their mouth
muscles some of these are things you
might expect like controlling your
breathing and learning to speak on the
breath hi how are you some of them are
less expected like the jaw throat and
tongue warm-ups the actors do before
they get in the booth most people their
tension is in their jaw so I'm using
these fingers to hold the jaw not clinch
the jaw but hold it and I'm gonna take a
diaphragmatic breath in so if I go
now I'm gonna do it on sound hi it's key
to have a relaxed open back of the
throat as opposed to a tense and fixed
back of the throat which means that
sometimes the breath can't go out the
mouth so it has to go shoot out the nose
and that's when you get things like
nasality nasal might actually work for
certain characters of course I want to
keep racing this is my backyard but in
most roles actors want to speak more
deeply and roundly so their voices can
capture a fuller range of emotional
expression out of curiosity why wouldn't
you want to bury me just you know again
purely for curiosity the little dingy
thing in the back is called the uvula
most peoples are frozen and they are
kind of stuck so there's exercises like
you'll hear a voiceover people do that
in abundance and it's to exercise the
uvula in the back so that it's almost
like a punching bag the way it moves
clever tongue twisters are another key
part of actors warm-up routines what
everyone knows is Peter Piper picked a
peck of pickled peppers but there's a
lot of tongue twisters that aren't
necessarily long but they really help
nip in the bud certain pronunciations
abominable abdominals abominable
abdominals abominable abdominals
abominable abdominals kinky cookie
cookie cookie cookie cookie lemon lime
liniment lemon lime liniment eleven
benevolent elephants try it 11
yeah that's why it that's why it's in
there these exercises help to relieve
tension but even some seasoned doctors
will still get nervous once I hop in
front of the mic their throat gets dry
their tongue gets dry when you're
talking you have a look there's a lot of
lip smacking what I'll do is I will eat
a green apple the acids that give green
apples they're sour taste also can
stimulate saliva production this helps
clean and moisten the mouth reducing
problems like lip smacking and mic
clicks some people have the opposite
problem they produce too much saliva
when they're worked up so they sound
like you're a little drunk but they're
nervous luckily there's a quick fix for
actors who hypersalivation to mic what I
tell them to do is take coffee grinds
just a pinch and put it underneath your
tongue and what absorb the coffee grinds
aren't tasty that is not good but they
do dry up excess saliva minimizing the
sound of a wet mouth a unique problem
arises in the booth when actors are
pronouncing words beginning with P B D G
or T
you're welcome Batman besides I knew the
cops would let you go these sounds are
called closest it's these air vibrations
that are the foundation of beatboxing
[Music]
but not so much in voice acting that
bursts of air is very loud and dramatic
one of the simplest ways to get rid of
that so if you have a pencil in front of
your microphone and you're speaking when
you say something like pee it gets
stopped by the pencil contrary to what
people might think voice acting can
actually be very physical you can
conduct yourself much the way of a
symphony conductor works with an
orchestra when he wants something legato
and easy and when he wants big motions
and you can do that with your hands and
your in your body if I wanted to say
many moaning men I want that to be
legato
smooth and loving so I can use my hands
like a conductor and go many moaning men
if I wanted to be sharper with a many
moaning men so your voice follows your
body if I said take a Superman pose and
now say many moaning men making money it
changes as I put your hands on the
lectern and become the president then
it's going to change the way you speak I
say put your hands on your hip and start
moving your head then all of a sudden
now yeah you're getting down and this
often comes up in voice acting where the
script is saying that you're at a
baseball game let's just say and then
there's atmosphere you know the fans are
going crazy but there's still dialogue
happening right one of the things that
we have to do is we have to talk over
like as if there's a crowd there but
that's not yelling it is talking over
the crowd or the noise right so I was
working with someone and they just kept
yelling into the microphone so I finally
said to him use your hands as if a wave
was coming up and over so that while
you're saying the line you're going to
say the line as if you're talking up and
over so when he finally did that he was
stunned in live-action films the actors
have sets costumes makeup and practical
effects to help them get into character
in animated films actors have their
imaginations when you're working on a
particular script it may call for a
certain mood maybe it starts up with oh
it's cold in here and so okay so this is
gonna be a cold experience but you're in
the booth you don't have the people with
you you don't have the props you don't
have a real environment and you have to
create a lot lemon/lime liniment women
line
ah